So the other day I was just surfing YouTube
listening to some nostalgic tunes, and I come
upon a video containing the Wii Menu Music.
Now for whatever reason I decided to scroll
down into the comments to see what people
had to say about the music, but I ended noticing
some really weird and kind of disturbing comments
so I thought I would share them with you in
this video.
So this person says, "Am I the only one that
finds this soothing?
Like hypnotic?"
And I was think, yes, it's soothing, but hypnotic?
I'm not really so sure about that.
But to my surprise I looked at the replies
to the comment and there were quite a few
people who agreed with him and said, "Same."
Then there's somebody else that claims sometimes
I just randomly hear this.
And again, there were quite a few people who
experienced the same thing.
One of which said, "IT JUST MELTS INTO YOUR
MIND, CONSUMING IT.
WII MENU IS LOVE.
WII MENU IS LIFE."
So I found it kind of strange that people
were agreeing with these weird comments and
then I see this.
"I hear it if it's pitch quiet at night, except
for the dishwasher.
For some reason, my brain interprets the dishwasher
sounds as this music."
So I thought surely that nobody else would
agree with that one, but I was wrong because
this person chimes in: "Same."
And I just find it strange that something
that specific would be shared by multiple
people.
"That song ends up playing when you randomly
wake up at 2AM and this is the song that you
hallucinate hearing."
"My Wii turns on by itself.
Can anyone tell me why?
(2 hours later) Wait a second...
Isn't my Wii dead?
OMG IT'S THE WII SPIRIT IS POSSESSING IT'S
BODY!"
OK can somebody-- what's going on??
What's the deal with this?
"Sometimes when I'm not near the Wii I just
randomly hear this music."
"Oh yeah, me too bro."
"I'm crying.
I can hear the little clicks right now.
You all know what I'm talking about."
"You can make a religion out of this."
Yeah of course the person with a Pokemon profile
picture would be talking about making a religion
out of the frickin' Wii music.
"I've had this stuck in my head for the last
24 hours.
HELP."
The weird thing about this is while this music
is soothing or whatever, it isn't like the
catchiest or poppiest of music.
It's not something I would really find getting
stuck in my head.
I mean, I can think of worse things to have
stuck in your head for 24 hours, but that's
an insanely long amount of time.
"Scientists believe that this sound is that
last thing a human being hears at the point
of death.
Could this be God himself?"
Maybe this guy should join the Pokemon guy's
religion...
OK, this one's just ridiculous, this one's
off the charts.
"The song is very depressing for me.
Some awful memories and incidents happened
when this music played back in 2007."
Well, first of all, them me stop you there.
I don't know what happened to this person
but if there are awful things happening around
you and these scarring incidents are taking
place... why do you still have the Wii on?
And furthermore, if someone's using the Wii,
why would they leave it on the menu thing.
In my experience, you boot it up, you hear
this music for less than a minute while you
choose which game you want to play.
"I even have the dates of those things marked
in my Wii Calendar, and it still makes me
sad for a bit.
For some reason, I still like it."
Like...
WHAT?
First of all, who uses the Wii Calendar?
I can only imagine.
'Yeah.
Uhm.
Dad came home drunk again and killed Mom...
I'm gonna go mark this in my Wii Calendar...."
Again I have no idea what happened to this
person, hopefully it's nothing too bad.
This freaking song drives me insane.
I have no idea why."
Yeah.. neither do I.
No!
No, no, that's impossible!
No, I left you behind!
We were finished!
I moved on!
I bought the Nintendo Switch for $299.99!